this is the birthplace of syria's
uprising in 2011
but opposition members call this moment
the end
of the dream of a democratic country
it's 2018
and the government has just recaptured
the southern province after seven years
of resistance
i almost had a breakdown after all the
sacrifices
when they raised the flag we felt
stabbed the town had a lot of symbolism
for the revolution
it was here where the wall of fear was
broken we watched
syrians turn against the police state we
watch them bury
their dead demonstrators who were killed
by security forces
protests spread to other areas
in homs tanks were sent to suppress the
uprising
the city which became known as the
capital of the revolution became a
battleground
the regime forced us to take up arms and
turned the uprising into a war
it was no longer possible to face guns
without screams
there was a siege on the rebel
stronghold after months of heavy
fighting
months later the opposition agreed to
leave the area
ashraf was among them he says they had
little choice
they were trapped without basic supplies
running low
on ammunition and abandoned by the world
two years later and after a four-year
stalemate the opposition was forced to
abandon aleppo
which weakened them politically
i felt broken when i got on the bus i
still think about it
but the siege was unbearable people were
dying either by bombs or hunger
is among the millions of internally
displaced syrians who live in the
opposition controlled north
unable and unwilling to live under
syrian president bashar al-assad's rule
but he says he fears a ceasefire agreed
last year
will not hold already hundreds of
thousands have been killed
millions have been displaced inside and
outside the country
and there has been no accountability
syria's conflict is entering its second
decade with the majority of its citizens
poor
and with little hope
we have been forced to give up on our
dreams the international community has
failed the syrian people
there is no reconciliation there is no
peace ten years of war has divided a
country
and its people senator al-jazeera beirut